if you love The Little Rascals you might
be wondering how those kids turned out
so what do we know about the actor who
played Dara the 1990s were a great
decade of movies many of which are the
source of considerable Nostalgia
nowadays take the Little Rascals for
example the movie every '90s kid had on
VHS and which never got old no matter
how many times we watched it still even
though time has obviously passed for the
cast of The Little Rascals just as it
did for the rest of us it's still
shocking to see them all grown up the
story sends on alala Spanky and the rest
of the He-Man Woman Haters Club but
there was one little girl alala had a
soft spot for Dara played by Britany
Ashton Holmes Holmes stole the show with
her sassy attitude and belief in
standing up for herself despite being so
young I'm in touch with my feminine side
how nice it's worse than I thought she
even snagged a few awards for her
breakout performance such as the young
artist award which she won alongside her
co-stars the 25th anniversary of The
Little Rascals came in 2019 leading us
to wonder what is the cast of The Little
Rascals up to today and in particular
little dala after winning breakout roles
childhood stars often go on to have very
successful careers with a number of
notable Parts on their resume while
Holmes did go on to play in a handful of
TV movies and even had an appearance in
a McDonald's commercial in 1995 she
didn't appear in anything at all after
1996 until 2014 that is that year homes
played the role of Town's lady Brit in
the Ron Livingston Le AMC pilot we hate
Paul Rivier other notable roles from the
1990s include Cynthia coats in death
benefit and girl on boat in humanoids
from the deep it's not entirely clear
why Holmes seemingly retired from acting
but it stands the reason that she just
didn't want to remain in the spotlight
anymore and by the looks of it education
became her main focus as she got older
when she was old enough Holmes pursued a
degree in political science and not much
more as known than that while E 2020
cast retrospective shed little more
light on homes's current Endeavors the
piece also confirmed perhaps
unsurprisingly that alala and Dara
didn't end up together in real life as
of 2017 bug hall is married to a woman
named Jill Marie degra and holes
apparently scooped up a husband herself
besides the Myspace page she had in the
early to mid 2000s however her social
media presence is pretty sparse there's
nothing wrong with not being present on
social media of course but if you're
dying to know if her husband is a fan of
The Little Rascals you might be waiting
a while to find out that said Holmes
made an appearance for the 20th
anniversary of The Little Rascals in
2014 she agreed to get back together
with the rest of the gang to recreate
some of the most iconic shots from the
movie Brian pocrass the founder of the
company that stays the reunion told
HuffPost that Holmes wasn't into doing
the reunion until he convinced her that
it was more about the film than the
Tabloid appe and when she was reunited
with her castmates holes seemed to fall
right back into play at the event she
said I liked wearing that red sparkly
dress the whole movie was a dream apart
from that small part in a movie homes
took in the same year as a reunion it's
probably safe to assume that she's not
going to be returning to screens anytime
soon over the last few decades it seems
she has been out there doing her own
thing and enjoying the privacy of an
ordinary
life